all right justin bieber took canadiana
to a whole new level when he teamed up
with tim hortons to launch his tim beams
tim bits last fall that collaboration
actually helped push tim horton's sales
up by 10 in the fourth quarter 2021 and
11
dip the year prior so it's no surprise
that tim's is looking to make more magic
with justin this time they've announced
biebs brew
a french vanilla cold brew co-created
with the biebs himself the new drink is
set to launch june 6th along with the
return of tim biebs tim beams were super
popular in my house they were
but is this not an already existing
drink at tim hortons that they're just
sort of rebranding well if you have to
ask that question then this is what they
had to do right yeah if you didn't know
that then then repackaging it and
selling it to your brand new but that
was right move but i will i will say
that i will say this in defense of all
the tim beam stuff at first i was you
know you roll your eyes a little bit
right tim beams
and then i just you're walking around
and you see people wearing the gear and
then you see people cannot get enough
and they're selling out and then you
look at the the results of teaming up
with bieber and it was actually you know
a perfect partnership why not go back
again i think that they do this for
years did you get the g did you get the
gear do you have any of the gear i don't
have the gear i tried i tried the timber
if you have it you got to hold on to it
it's worth 20 years from now
bro i'm telling you paying for your home
with tim biebs t-shirt but this right
here this is this should be like you
know jordan and like this is air
jordan's here you know what i mean
this should be here
this should be his partnership for life
he really believes that he's going to
start don't say it out loud because then
he starts his own thing true